les critiques se multiplient toujours à
l'approche justement de cette Coupe du
Monde qui commence dimanche au Qatar
depuis son attribution au Qatar en 2010
l'événement et le sujet de toutes sortes
de critiques dont on va parler avec Ray
Lalande ce soir expert en affaires et
marketing sportif bonsoir et la longue
alors cette Blatter qui était Président
de la FIFA à l'époque de l'octroi de la
coupe au Qatar avait déclaré que c'était
une erreur aussi de donner en tout cas
il le dit la semaine passée la semaine
dernière dès le départ le vote a été
entaché par toutes sortes de magouilles
rappelez-nous est-ce que c'est passé ben
il y avait beaucoup de pays candidats
dont les États-Unis qui sont devenus les
finalistes finalement les États-Unis
auront les la prochaine Coupe du Monde
2026 avec le Canada et le Mexique mais
c'était un choix quand même étrange un
pays qui n'a pas vraiment une longue
histoire ou culture de soccer il y a des
pays comme le Brésil l'Argentine
l'Espagne la France l'Allemagne l'Italie
les États-Unis bien sûr qui vivent et
qui respirent du soccer de façon
constante pour avoir la Coupe du monde
en 98 Géral en France c'est un événement
qui fait le tour du pays on a des stades
partout c'est vraiment un mois complet
d'une immersion totale dans ce sport le
c'est merveilleux passe une célébration
d'un rassemblement sportif mondial mais
au Qatar une population deux points 8
millions de personnes beaucoup de
visiteurs maintenant permanents là-bas
c'est pas justifiable il y avait pas de
raison de choisir le Qatar à part du
fait que on a influencé sous toutes
sortes de formes incluant des paiements
illicites le vote des membres de la FIFA
qui a fait en sorte que on a décidé d'y
aller prendre un risque énorme pour
aller dans un pays qui n'a pas la
culture ou la structure pour accueillir
un événement de sûr alors soupçonne de
corruption d'abord et avant tout ensuite
une estimation de 6500 travailleurs
étrangers morts au Qatar depuis 2010 ça
circule ce n'est pas un nombre de décès
liés directement
l'histoire du sport alors c'est un
paquet de raisons comme ça qui font en
sorte que c'est un choix qui était
indécent à l'époque qu'il est tout
encore aujourd'hui puis qui va être
éclairé là avec la présence des médias
du monde entier sur place cette semaine
mais les appels au boycottage ont-ils
été entendu non non ni par les équipes
ni par les pays au Canada on est tous
heureux parce que c'est la première
participation du Canada en 36 ans alors
on est festif on est content on va
suivre la performance de l'équipe Canada
aux États-Unis aussi participe le côté
sportif ont toujours tendance à dire
nous on est là pour jouer au soccer on
est là pour faire mais on oublie que
c'est un message important à la planète
ce qui se passe derrière tout ça les
6500 travailleurs c'est des individus
comme toi et moi qui sont deux pays
défavorisés qui ont accepté des emplois
qui ont laissé leur famille derrière
pour ensuite envoyer le chèque de paye
pendant des mois et des années puis qui
sont décédés sur place on en fait quoi
de ça alors c'est un sujet qui est très
délicat le monde sportif pour le
se prend un peu de recul en essayant de
ne pas se mêler à la politique mais il y
a pas de façon de ne pas se mêler mais
les grands pays vont absolument dites la
France par exemple les Bleus l'équipe de
France permet de financer des actions à
impact social avec une partie de la
somme qui le reviendra est-ce qu'on
s'achète une bonne conscience on
s'achète une bonne confiance puis je
dois dire une chose au sujet de la
France catharis porte une baisse mais
propriétaire à 100% du Paris
Saint-Germain une des équipes de sport
les plus célèbres l'argent arabe de tout
cet univers là du Moyen-Orient et de du
centre de l'Europe
investit beaucoup dans les équipes de
foot de Manchester City de Newcastle de
du PSG de Barcelone qui pendant des
années Géral avec
Qatar Airways sur leur chandail alors on
est tous entre mêlé la danse et
difficile de s'en sortir par là est-ce
que la FIFA est-ce que le monde Soccer
est en taché faire ça et ce qu'on doit
se réjouir que le Canada fasse partie de
la coupe de 2026 ben sur le plan sportif
oui on est heureux parce qu'on l'a pas
vu de notre génération ça fait 36 ans du
côté de la FIFA c'est eux qui sont
responsables de ce choix-là c'est eux
qui ont mené à ça pour des raisons
financières encore une fois c'est pas
parce que on va s'en sortir avec plus
d'argent comment faire de l'argent quand
ça va nous en coûter 230 milliards pour
accueillir le monde entier mais ce qu'on
veut c'est encore une fois une fois de
plus changer un peu comment les gens
nous perçoivent les Jeux Olympiques de
Pékin en février dernier même principe
la Coupe du Monde de 2018 en Russie même
principe on s'achète ces grands
événements le sportif pour se dissimuler
derrière et cacher un peu le vrai visage
de ces pays-là qui sont très
controverses mais le vrai visage finit
par apparaître de toute façon réalonde
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]